lea está instalando azulejos en el piso
de un baño ella tiene azulejos grandes y
chicos los azulejos grandes tienen un
área de 5 pies cuadrados
voy a subrayarlo con el mismo color y
los chicos tienen un área de 2 pies
cuadrados 2 pies cuadrados el área total
del piso es de 40 pies cuadrados si l
es el número de azulejos grandes usados
y ese el número de azulejos chicos
usados podemos escribir la siguiente
ecuación veamos si hace sentido esta
ecuación aquí tenemos el el número de
azulejos grandes que multiplicamos por 5
pies que es el área que ocupa cada
azulejo así es que esta expresión nos da
el área que ocupan todos los azulejos
grandes y el área que ocupa los azulejos
chicos es 12 s 2 pies cuadrados por cada
azulejo por el número de azulejos chicos
y sabemos que el área total del piso es
40 si sumamos el área cubierta por los
azulejos chicos y el área cubierta por
los azulejos grandes nos da 40 al sumar
estas dos cosas nos da 40 esto hace
sentido estoy total
de acuerdo con la ecuación y que nos
piden cuál de estas combinaciones de
azulejos permite cubrir exactamente todo
el piso del baño
así es que cubrir exactamente todo el
piso del baño nos están aclarando que no
quieren que cubramos ni de más ni de
menos el piso del baño por lo cual para
hacer esto necesitamos sustituir estos
valores de azulejos y ver si se verifica
esta ecuación empecemos con estos
valores nos dan 6 azulejos grandes l 6
mientras que el número de azulejos
chicos s es igual a 5 verifiquemos si
esta combinación cubre exactamente el
piso del baño
sustituyamos los valores en la ecuación
tenemos entonces 5 x l que es igual a 6
más
por s que es igual a 52 por 5 y esto a
cuánto es igual esto es igual a 5 por
630 más 2 por 5 10 y si se cumple la
ecuación 30 más 10 es igual a 40 así es
que esta primera si cumple con la
ecuación que tenemos aquí veamos la
segunda combinación parece que esto no
va a cumplir pues si la primera
combinación teníamos seis grandes y
cinco chicos y cubrió exactamente el
piso
aquí tenemos seis grandes y seis chicos
no va a cumplir pero verifiquemos esto
en la ecuación esto nos da cinco por el
número de azulejos grandes que es 6 5
por 6 azulejos grandes él es igual a 6
más 2 por el número de azulejos chicos
que es 6 y esto va a ser igual 5 por 6
+ 2 x 6 12 y esto es 42 que
definitivamente esto es distinto de 40
no cumple la ecuación si nos hubieran
pedido que combinación alcanza para
cubrir el piso entonces ésta
correspondería pero como nos están
pidiendo que lo cubra exactamente no voy
a seleccionar esta opción ahora qué pasa
con 7 azulejos chicos y 5 azulejos
grandes este caso tampoco parece que va
a funcionar porque aquí tenemos
exactamente el mismo número de azulejos
chicos no pero déjame corregir esto aquí
invirtieron el orden estos son azulejos
grandes aquí hay 7 azulejos chicos y 5
azulejos grandes 7 azulejos chicos y 5
azulejos grandes veamos
si esto funciona tenemos 5 pies
cuadrados de cada azulejo grande por el
número de azulejos grandes que en este
caso son 5 azulejos grandes y a eso
tenemos que sumarle 2 pies cuadrados por
cada azulejo chico que en este caso son
7 azulejos chicos esto nos va a dar 5 x
5 25
2 x 7 14 nos da 39 39 es distinto de 40
así es que este caso no funciona
finalmente 10 azulejos chicos y 4
azulejos grandes
veamos si funciona para 4 azulejos
grandes tenemos 5 pies cuadrados por 4
azulejos grandes éste es el área que
cubren los azulejos grandes ya esto
tenemos que sumarle 2 pies cuadrados por
cada azulejo chico es decir 2 por 10
esto es lo que se cubre con azulejos
chicos y eso se le suma lo que se cubre
con azulejos grandes esto es igual a 20
más 20 que efectivamente coincide con 40
así es que este caso también funciona